they didn't always have hearings and i
think it's very reasonable at this point
even though republicans are having
hearings and democrats didn't want to
have hearings
i think it's very reasonable to say well
you know what we had hearings until you
trotted out people
who were knowingly false pawns accusing
a man of gang rape
and this is no longer productive that
changes the decorum
here we go with another change my mind
this time the topic that's on
everyone's mind voters
should pick the president and the
president
should pick the justice to be able to
jam this nomination through the senate
it's just an exercise in raw
political power leader mcconnell and the
republican senate
majority have no right to fill it this
is a man
who does not care about a dying
woman's final wish are you and joe biden
gonna pack the court if joe jamie coney
barrett is confirmed sir i've got to ask
you about packing the court well sir
don't the voters deserve to know
no they don't disagree i'm not going to
play his game you once again gave a
non-answer joe biden gave it anonymous
trying to answer you american people
deserve a straight answer some have
mentioned the possibility that you and
the house could move to impeach we have
our options we have arrows in our quiver
that is not a mandate and it's not
democracy
it's a [ __ ] travesty terrorist trump
must be defeated
must be destroyed and then he and his
enablers
and his supporters and the amy coney
barretts must be prosecuted and
convicted
and removed from our societies honestly
you have to get rid of the electoral
college we're gonna have to blow up the
entire system
talk talk talk but saying nothing i want
to know what do you think
should the senate confirm amy coney
barrett uh and if not
why not let me know in the comments
[Music]
below
[Applause]
okay let's get straight to it meet the
lovely anna grace
uh so ann i don't know how familiar you
are with what we do with change my mind
but the idea is that it's not a point
scoring session it's
really about rationalizing our positions
and um yeah this is going on right now
the hearings are going on right now so i
do want to let
how long does that bell go on well
there's three different balls and
they're not in sync so
a minute or so or longer and all the
chapel bells ringing okay
so um the hearings are going on so i
want to let anyone at home
know who's watching that you might say
something or i might say something that
could be apt to change because we're not
there for the hearings right now we
should be glued to our television sets
like it's a super bowl
uh but uh yeah right now this is seen
in the media is a controversial issue i
see no reason that uh
obviously a a qualified distinguished
judge like amy coney barrett should not
be confirmed to the united states
supreme court
uh if you see any reason as to why
you're more than welcome to change my
mind would you welcome a
step forward a little bit just because
we want to be in the boundaries of this
table yeah sure thank you
okay so i think first off because it's
like an outstanding circumstance like
it's an election year
and um we're in the midst of an election
we don't know who's going to win
you know we're hearing like different
opinions we don't know who's going to
win
so i think we should wait till the
president is elected or reelected
and to make that decision then second of
all even if it wasn't an election year
i as a woman i don't feel protected or
represented by
amy barry amy coney barrett and i feel
like it's a mouthful
yeah acb acb is replacing uh
the very woman who did so many amazing
things for
women's rights and just human rights as
a feminist she believed
in equality right and so she really
fought for like one of the like biggest
cases that she fought for was for a man
and how he was
treated differently because or you know
there was uh
there was sexist behavior towards him
because he was a man and that wasn't
fair like that shouldn't
sex should not be in the equation at all
and i think there's a lot actually to
admire about our
rgb even though i disagree with her on a
whole lot uh i'd like to set that aside
for a second because
there's a difference between you or i
not
liking a judge or their opinions and of
course the constitutional authority to
appoint and confirm them to the supreme
court so we can go back to that in those
opinions and i would like to
um but the first point you made is that
you don't think we should confirm
acb because it's an election year yeah
like not
not make the decision until whoever is
going to be
leading us for four more years i think
that's why um because there might be a
change
okay you know that would be silly for
donald trump to like
for her to be elected and then the
person who fought so hard for her
and even elected her is not even in
office anymore
well i don't understand why that would
be silly because you know the president
is president for four years
yeah but his this term is almost over
sure yeah but the term isn't over
so he has four years as a presidency i
mean i guess i don't understand so
you're not arguing that constitutionally
he doesn't have the authority or the
senate doesn't have the authority to
confirm
you're saying it's just maybe because of
these circumstances because it's an
election year this only happens
every four years and yeah you know and i
think but i guess what would you base
that other than you
feel like it's inappropriate well
um i just think that because
of an election year we should wait to
who's going to be leading for the next
four years
now let me ask you this and i understand
because that's a sentiment that i've
heard expressed quite a bit
do you think that maybe that's been
instilled in you perhaps to a degree by
biased professors
or media because it's a very very new
opinion what
the idea that you can't appoint a
supreme court justice in an election
year
um well this is my second election that
i've been able to vote in okay
historically uh historically yeah have i
been
i mean historically this is a very new
idea that a president should only
act as president for three years as a
matter of fact you know rpg who we both
said we've respected
she said that the president of course is
elected for four years and should act as
president
and he should absolutely nominate a
justice in an election year
she said that she was very clear about
that as a matter of fact this is not
her dying wishes according to her
granddaughter that can't actually be
verified this is her publicly written
opinion
she wrote this years ago yeah and she
wrote this uh while barack obama was
president i believe
and it was something that was taken from
the supreme court we're talking about
right now that's not that long ago it
was about three years ago
um do you know how many times years ago
do you know how many i'm going to
continue
finishing my thought here do you know
how many times um
a president has nominated a supreme
court justice in an election year no
idea
29 times now 29 times they've been
elected
so that's actually a very good question
because when it's a shared party uh
government where it's not a divided
government meaning
right the three branches of government
are executive tradition you know what it
means oh no listen it's okay i'm not man
spending my spending for people watching
at home
judiciary and that's why i really like
this uh this example right now because
it's a perfect example of
this amalgamate that is three branches
of government that are equal but
separate and particularly more
autonomous as the court
so uh ten out of those scenarios we had
the same party in charge of the
executive
and uh legislative branch and in all ten
times they confirmed
there was one exception with a man named
abe abe i forgot his last name uh and
now is because he was forced to resign
due to ethics issues
but those were already underway so yeah
29 times a president in an election year
an outgoing president has
nominated someone and when it's been a
shared party for president in the
legislature
it's confirmed and that's ten times
that's nine out of the ten times barring
the one exception with a because of
ethics issues yeah
so there's a long-standing president as
a matter of fact it would be a violation
of american president and decorum
to not confirm them
so i guess what what would you be and
i've heard this quite a bit but i don't
i mean she goes against like so much of
what
of so much of the progress that we've
made from the supreme court justice that
she's going to be replacing mm-hmm
that sits okay with you do you care
about women's rights and
do i care about women's rights yes i do
but what does that have to do with
confirming amy coney
i don't think that she's the best fit to
begin with so is that the litmus test
for why we should not confirm injustice
no it's the election year as i first
said but okay but the election year but
then
you want to go deeper then yeah it's
also that she's
okay but you said the election year have
we addressed the election year that
there's
29 times precedent so this is so you
don't like it you don't feel
good about it no i told you
that it was because of an election year
got like this this has been this year
has been a mess for so many reasons
and i don't know why we couldn't just
wait a little bit longer to make that
decision
when someone's elected i guess the
question becomes again
you would have to justify you have to
rationalize that reason considering that
it goes against precedent
waiting to nominate that's not what we
do that's not what obama did
that's not what's happened 29 times you
nominate you're the president that's
what you do
and if you're the senate you confirm or
you reject that's what you do
so i don't understand the reasoning i
guess that is a good point
i'm thinking but no no i appreciate it i
just i've heard your argument made a
good point i know i'm thinking
um but let's go and i appreciate you
being open mind let's go to that so
the second side is you don't like where
acb lines up
which is separate and aside from us
having the ability to confirm her and i
think we're in different territory so i
appreciate it
um okay so you don't like what she
stands for
but how again does that affect but no
but but that's not my argument for why i
think that there should be a way and i
just think that it's because
in the climate of everything that's
going on it's just this has
been a horrible year for so many reasons
and i didn't know that that
was the case when obama was president
and stuff so i didn't know that um
yeah i don't know i just felt like there
should be time i think that it was just
such a quick
he was so quick to nominate her and i
never even heard her name before
so really yeah and so for well she was
on a list that he actually released
before he was president do you know that
no so this is important because i think
this matters i think we would both agree
that transparency matters
in a presidency right president trump
get transparent
president trump released his list of
potential supreme court justices
before he was president and then he
re-released it while he was president
uh joe biden hasn't really sent it he
said he'll only do it after election
just like we'd have to find out his
opinion on court packing until after the
election
so the fact that you hadn't read of her
name i mean she was obviously she's been
a justice on the
seventh court seventh circuit court
she's been around for a while she's been
vetted
and she was on donald trump's list of
justices
is that surprising that you haven't
heard anything about her i mean i
probably have heard her name i don't
know but i just didn't know
much about her and then um when he made
that announcement
two weeks or however long ago just
everything that comes out about
how doesn't seem like anyone will be
representing women in the supreme court
and that's really disheartening
um and i just wish that we could wait a
second but i understand why we can't
i'm not gonna change your mind no i
understand where you're coming from
so how would um three women on the
supreme court not represent any women in
the supreme court
well not all women are feminists okay
and by when i say i guess yeah they're
representing us by being women and being
on there but if they're not fighting for
us
then it's just like we could be
represented by a male feminist
i think not those women aren't fighting
for
um our rights like our abortion rights
are being
um harmed by her being elected
and yeah but there are male feminists on
the court so there are three women there
will be three women on the court when we
can form acb
and uh there are male feminists on the
court
okay so do you mean that the court is
not complete unless there's specific i
just wanted to
there will never be another ruth peter
ginsberg so i shouldn't hope for one
yeah
that's probably true there will never be
another ruth bader ginsburg it'll never
be another
uh uh scalia either yeah i think that's
true and i think she was a formidable
woman in a lot of ways
um and i think that a lot of people sort
of buy into this mythos of rbg
uh without really understanding where
she lined up on a lot of issues
yeah um i mean i don't know if you know
this but she said that uh roby wouldn't
she didn't agree with it completely i
know yeah but um
and she was vehemently against packing
the courts very much so
she said it's it's the one thing you
could do to absolutely erode trust in
the institution
of the judicial branch would be to pack
those courts so i think
yeah i understand where you're coming
from and listen there's always obviously
i want to rationalize our positions
logically but i understand when you lose
someone important
obviously this is an emotional uh topic
to cover right now but i think the best
way we can at least honor rbg is
to honor her written and expressed
wishes which is don't pack those courts
and to point nominate confirm um someone
in
an election year which is what she was
what she was supportive
uh and i actually think that acb would
be a better representative than
than maybe you might anticipate and who
i said i think that acb might be
a better representation than you might
anticipate because i know that you
haven't really read a whole lot about
that though
well because i know that you haven't
really read a whole lot about her
haven't heard of her
i brought a few things okay just i i
didn't know who she was before he
uh before like she was all over the news
and stuff okay but why
why why should i feel um like i'm gonna
like her more
i said i said i think she may be a
better representative than you think
because she's an original she's a
constitutionalist okay
so this isn't someone who is uh nearly
as much of a judicial activist
as some other judges have been both on
the left and the right
so um i think if you actually look into
her uh decisions and even into some of
her dissenting opinions
you might and i could be wrong this is
just i think you might find yourself
pleasantly surprised and i would
encourage you
to to read up on her a little bit okay
okay i will
thank you and i appreciate that
hopefully i don't know when we do the
fist from the air fist bumps
[Music]
see that wasn't entirely unpleasant and
uh if you want these installments to
change my mind to continue please do
consider joining mug club
it's 69 annually for students veterans
active military you get this wonderful
hand etched mug
along with a full daily show that's not
available here on youtube
if you go to lotto with crowder.com mug
club
along with the entire blaze tv catalog
if not i ask that you hit the
notification bell and
check in because we broadcast live here
every weekday morning
at 10 a.m eastern let's get back to it
meet the next gentleman
thatcher nice to meet what's your name
thatcher like margaret thatcher exactly
okay very nice do you need me to put
this mask on here i don't care
okay all right thatcher uh so thatcher i
think you've been here as we've been
discussing this all day
uh i see no reason to not confirm amy
coney bear to the supreme court
i haven't heard anything even really
approaching a convincing argument i
understand why people don't like it
uh and that's valid not seeing a
constitutional or a legal reason to not
confirm her but
if you think i've got a blind spot i'm
more than happy to hear you
i don't think there's a constitution or
a legal reason to
not confirm her because the things work
both ways packing the court joe biden
can do it
so can donald trump but i think that
what we really need to think about is
that
is this the most important thing to be
talking about uh
we have an economic crisis going on the
worst one we've seen since 2008
and although people that are more
interested in politics like you and
everyone who's around here
we all want to see someone in the
supreme court the average american is
just worried about where their next
check is coming from and if it's not
coming from one of the businesses that
our
government so graciously closed down uh
then it ought to come from the
government itself and so i think we need
to see another relief package
before they're worrying about this i
think you've uh i appreciate what you
just said i agree with some of what
you've just said
i think some gross misrepresentations
there all right um and i think that's
your first mistake let's try and
nip this in the bud and not continue
this way because it's not going to be
productive discussion if you say
as people like you and everyone around
here yes only care about politics in
relation to economics
no i'm an average everyday working
american too i have 15 people who work
for me
that's why i have opinions on the
coronavirus that's why i do the show
that i do
and i certainly talk about the economy
and i certainly talk about macro issues
more often than supreme court
this is a topical issue because hearings
are going on today so i think it's a
valid topic to discuss is that fair
yeah okay so let's not misrepresent me
or people here is only caring about
micro politics
of course we all care about where our
paycheck is coming from and that's why
this is where i agree with you i do not
believe that it's within the
government's authority to as you put it
so gracious
graciously shut us all down and so it is
their duty now to
make sure that uh basically some kind of
retribution some kind of
justification here right some kind of
compensation is what i think you're
talking about
um i think that's why we passed the
biggest stimulus bill that we have in
in modern certainly recent american
history um and uh there are two ways to
go about it right now
open the economy back up or spend more
of taxpayer dollars now let's go back to
amy coney bear
uh from what i understand you're saying
there is no reason to not confirm
uh i would say yeah no legally
constitutionally i don't see any reason
not to confirm her
i would say it's just in our people like
our american people's interest to see
um a stimulus package addressed
more fervently than this they take
things one at a time they're very very
slow
government is very slow very very slow
they're equipped to shut businesses down
slow to provide some kind of relief if
there's any way they can act
in their own interests and tyrannically
they move as quickly as possible sure
uh but if it's in the american people's
interest it takes as many years as
they'd like it to
which is why i'd like to see this be the
thing that we address and not amy coney
barrett
uh i think that can wait until after the
let me ask you this and i understand
where you're coming from on that
um and i also think this is a wonderful
representation of talking to others
about this today of the three branches
of government how they act as checks and
balances
so it sounds to me using words like
tyrannical sounds like you have a
problem with the way the government
shutdown people's business
absolutely okay so we would agree on
that well what acts as a check and
balance
on executive orders or the legislative
branch
sorry what acts as a check and a balance
right we have the executive the
legislative
and the judicial judiciary yes right and
there have been plenty of rulings in the
past that have said well this is
actually this is an abuse of
unconstitutionally
non-constitutionally delegated authority
they don't have the authority to make
this decision
so i think that two things can both be
true i think that both are equally
important
i think that right now having a supreme
court who understands people who are
constitutionalists people who are
originalists and people who want to
limit the power by the way
both to the executive office and the
legislative office i think we both agree
with that whether you support donald
trump or joe biden
i don't want the next guy abusing that
power that's where i think the supreme
court is equally
important because they might be able to
have a say in uh
what i would already argue is
unconstitutional shutting down
businesses and be a safeguard against
that that's why we have the three
branches so
would we maybe agree that doing both
would be ideal
uh yes with a healthy dose of reopening
up yes i would i would agree that a very
healthy dose of rio opening up is needed
um and if if that can happen then that
cuts out our need for a ginormous
stimulus package i would much rather see
every business open total capacity
then trillions of dollars be given away
but i would rather see trillions of
dollars being given away
than us focusing on this woman who yes
she's going to have an impact for the
next 10 20 30 years of her life
but what we need right now is money
because people are focused on getting
their
food on their table today tomorrow not
worried about 10 20 years down the line
necessarily
i i would agree with what you're saying
in the easiest scenario where we could
do both
which would fall in line with precedent
of yep nominating a supreme court
justice during an election year
and it being confirmed when it's the
same party um would be like you said
reopening the economy
reopening the economy maybe some backlog
of stimulus for industries that were
unduly affected you know there are some
more than others um
then we could confirm the justice as
well i do agree with that
all right there we go we found some comm
look you came in hot not bad i think
we're friends yeah
thank you so much man thatcher yes
wonderful name strong woman thank you
look at that i changed my mind you'll
find it all even a friend
uh now let's uh sit stand up
down with chase i'm talking about this
today i don't know how familiar you are
with uh change my mind but the idea is
that we can
usually sit down yeah you need to get
those pants that have a seat you know a
little uh stools on them
legs uh but uh today we'll be standing
and talking about where we can
rationalize our positions on what are
considered controversial topics
right now obviously the hearings are
going on as we speak see no reason to
not confirm amy coney
emmy coney barrett to the supreme court
haven't heard anything today that's been
super convincing
um but i would love to hear from you
you're welcome to change my mind yeah so
like the clarification the reason that
you're
in favor is because she's a good person
she has like a clean record basically
and it's the president's job in the
sentence job
yeah has nothing to do with necessarily
i mean i agree with her views personally
okay
but that's not why i see no reason that
we can't go purchase there's
constitutionally there's
there's no reason not to legally there's
no reason not so we should just do it
just because it's
constitutionally allowed all right so
there's no reason not to okay
so six months from now you should be
arguing back here saying that joe biden
should pack the court because it's
constitutionally allowed well no i
wouldn't be arguing that joe biden
should back the court what i'm saying
right now is there's an argument against
confirming
amy coney barrett correct yeah and what
i'm saying is i'm not hearing any valid
argument as to why we can't
so so why can't we i guess but just to
break down the argument so the vowed
argument what's the valid argument for
against joe biden packing the court if
he wants this well let's first talk
about amy coney barrett because i know
you want to go straight to what about is
i mean i would like to talk about courts
but first let's address let's address
you can change my mind
because that's the sign yeah so where am
i wrong what i'm arguing is i'm
saying that we're the same okay as i'm
saying we should confirm her
yeah no no no what i'm saying is i don't
think we should confirm her because i
disagree with her politically and i'm
saying you don't think
that joe biden in the senate should pack
the court because you would disagree
with that politically
no why not it's the same argument but
it's not it's not what i said it is the
exact same argument stephen it is
they can do it you can use my name and
try and use these uh
charming techniques that you've probably
learned somewhere in debate 101 but
that's not what i've said that's not my
point of view
is it is your smile on eyes i can't see
through that triple layer mask no that's
not what i said
now i would like to get to packing the
chords and why i think it's a problem
yeah but first
let's address this amy coney barrett
right now there are hearings going on
she will likely be confirmed
this is a big problem right now a lot of
people believe that she should not be
confirmed
you've approached me because you believe
for some reason she should not be
confirmed that reason is
because i think that she has bad
judicial views i don't think that
there's anything
super okay so because you don't like her
judicial
history yeah she shouldn't be yeah
appointed yeah the same reason that
merrick garland wasn't appointed was
because they didn't like his
who's this the senate in 2016 right okay
so listen there are two i want to make
sure i'm not
misunderstanding you maybe you're saying
that if you were in the senate
you wouldn't confirm her yeah okay but
you're not arguing that the senate
has no right to confirm her okay so you
would you don't have a problem with
this happening her being confirmed you
just don't like her as a judge
i don't i think they're the same thing
but yeah i know i'll agree with you that
i think i think that
well i think that i think that she
should be nominated then i also think
that joe biden
and the democrats should pack the court
okay yeah okay so you do think she
should be not nominated
confirmed yeah and then joe biden should
pack the court yeah because you believe
that they're one and the same yeah
okay so now we can get to your view on
packing the court yeah
hope has that been fair that we've
addressed that okay good so we both
agree there's no reason to not nominate
her and confirm her
um now you say that you support packing
the court
okay let me hear why you support back in
the court i think that
what we need to do is we need to do
exactly what's been done before and i
think that we need well not necessarily
what's been done before
i think that we need to preserve like
certain rights that i think are
important
i think that what we've seen is we've
seen the supreme court become
almost too powerful to an extent to
where donald trump is he'll be in office
for what four years
versus like the democrats be in office
in
eight years with obama and then probably
four years divided and
it's probably like an equal result for
the supreme court and i think that
basically the springboard is too
powerful we need to kind of like take
that in
and readdress it and kind of even it out
so you believe we should pack the courts
because we should dilute
the power of the supreme court yeah
probably yeah okay did you believe that
before
amy coney barrett yeah how long have you
believed that we should pack the court
i mean what in college i don't know like
freshman year i mean necessarily
i think one i think we should pack the
board right now but i also address those
certain rights
but i think that we need to change how
we're doing the supreme court so
we should pack the court right now yeah
to address certain rights so let me ask
you this back the court in case
anything important has been overturned
like aca or abortion
do you mean abortion to roe v wade uh
abortion
i don't think rugby waited so returned i
think you have like those laws out in
louisiana where they need like a
hospital
i think those become prevalent therefore
like ending what
want the state laws at that point yeah
but there it would become
okay they're still like it's a federal
rule so you believe we should pack the
courts
now uh do you believe donald trump
should pack the court said
no i think he wins oh
well trump would have no reason to pack
the court i think that sure he could why
not just extend his lead
because what i'm arguing is that i'm
saying it's purely political and i think
that what we need to do
is we need to make the supreme court not
so political we need to just change
completely how it's been done i think
i'm only arguing you're saying talk to
court i'm only arguing protect the court
if they overturn aca or other important
things okay well i just want to make
sure
because you said we should pack the
court now yeah pack the court
so but only if they change those things
now so not pack the court now
yeah because initially when you stood
here i don't i want to make sure i'm not
misrepresenting you but i
do think you said if she's nominated if
she's confirmed
pack the courts pack the courts joe
biden yeah right
but now you're saying only if aca or roe
v wade is overturned
yeah i'll argue that yeah i'll change my
beans just now yeah i'll argue okay so
but you do admit that it's a change and
i'm not
saying gotcha i want to make sure i
understand where you're coming from okay
if donald trump wins re-election which
is possible
should donald trump back the courts i
think that we need to have
fundamental change about how the supreme
court is run why can't donald trump do
that
i'd be glad if he did that i don't think
they'll do it i think that joe biden
should change how the supreme court is
run
i think but hold on a second why does
that have to be joe biden if you're
talking about this being
an issue with the supreme court why can
joe biden or why should joe biden pack
the courts and not donald trump
i just said oh pack the courts political
reasons i think that we need
to i think we need to protect a woman's
right to choose i think we need to
protect the uci now is the supreme court
supposed to be a political institution
like the executive or legislative branch
no
but you want it to be i don't want it to
be i'm saying that it is
no you said for political reasons we
should pack the course that's what you
just said
what am i getting is that we live in a
and we need to change anything that's
hurting an a and then change it to b
okay yeah but you just said you want to
do that for political reasons right
yeah because we live in a political you
believe that the court is too political
yes
when did it get to be too political
uh i don't know it's been political for
a while
it's been left tilting for a long while
yeah it's been right tilting before too
i mean
it's been left tilting for most of your
lifetime in my lifetime
yeah no i agree yeah um
do the opinions or for example wishes
of rbg play into your opinions at all
maybe but not not really no okay all
right just because i know a lot of
people been saying it's disrespect but
she was vehemently against
yeah court packing yeah and you
understand that and why do you think she
was
i mean i think because you have like
judicial legitimacy
i think that's a big thing and i think
that if you're in favor
if you want to like maintain judicial
legitimacy you shouldn't be
like rushing through a nomination when
most americans don't want it
well actually that's not true most
americans less than a third oppose amy
coney bear's nomination
a plurality of american supporters
pulling out the polling you're citing an
old poll from september it's not even
close
and that doesn't change the
constitutionality september was it like
a week away do you want to bring it up i
can bring you the poll look how many
look here's the thing the poll doesn't
determine constitutionality but you're
wrong i've seen at least like five holes
from like 538
pretty down the middle i've seen stuff
tweeted on nate silver's timeline
saying that it's like a 60 40 split or
whatever nate silver is the man who gave
hillary clinton was it 80 80
it was at 86 percent something about i
mean 15 20 is like
twenty like percent is still pretty high
okay um i take a twenty percent better
so there are two things here there are
there's a constitution the point is that
wrong by significant margin
um now there are two issues here there's
constitutionality there's a legality
and then there's polls yeah right polls
do not determine the constitutionality
or legality
yeah there is not constitutionally or
legally or as far as precedent there's
no argument to be made that they're
rushing this through this has happened
many times in american history 29
times a president in an outgoing
election year made a nomination
10 hours the only other one that would
be this fast would be rbg
the only other like there's like this
like how long did you mean
fast of a confirmation yeah i mean how
yeah there have been many
confirmations actually they were much
quicker for a long time i was telling
your friend uh
or sorry one of your colleagues here
earlier that they didn't even hold
hearings for 127 years
i mean how long was kavanagh that took
forever it took a long time
even even before with all the false
allegations of gang rape and yeah that's
the reason too that a lot of people are
saying let's return to 127 years of
precedent
where uh we don't allow one of our
people to have their reputation
legitimately uh through every single
legal document and avenue we have
available to us now proven
false the accusations of rape and gang
rape and brett kavanaugh
so yeah you can't prove him false you
can just sure you can julie swetnick or
canton
the gang rape one they said i was made
up what about there are many people who
come forward and says made up and then
the only one who didn't i haven't seen
christine blasey ford has no evidence
and the people who investigated said
there's no way
arguing that it was proven like the
gang rape yeah yeah i'm saying that like
there are many people who came out i'm
saying with dr ford's case they just
weren't able but that wasn't the only
case
now this is important because the reason
i'm bringing this up is when we're
talking about setting a precedent we're
talking about these hearings they didn't
always have hearings
and i think it's very reasonable at this
point and even though republicans are
having hearings and democrats didn't
want to have hearings
i think it's very reasonable to say well
you know what we had hearings until you
trotted out people
who were knowingly false pawns accusing
a man of gang rape
and this is no longer productive that
changes the decorum
i think that's a valid argument to make
yeah that man's
that man's reputation was destroyed
based on lines i mean they don't want
that to happen to any county baron
but that's why it was long it was long
because of lots well no it was long
before that it just
it took a while it was long because of
lies that was extended by like what a
week or two
i don't know there was an investigation
the initial investigation
then the calls for another investigation
something here you want to pronounce it
it took her a while to even like bring
that up so they didn't they weren't even
going through that until
it took a very very long time kavanaugh
is an exception to the rule
because of the lies that's my point let
me ask you this okay if we're going to
find common ground
do you believe that the length of the
kavanaugh hearings is the rule or the
exception
historically it's an exception yeah sure
it's not the rule
okay so let's agree on that let's not
try and say well this is too fast
because of brett kavanaugh
i would argue yeah it's actually a good
reason that this should be done more
quickly
because we can't let what happened with
brett kavanaugh happen with acb
but again we go back to this idea of the
constitutionality there is nothing
unconstitutional there's nothing illegal
about
confirming her to the supreme court and
then you were arguing outside of that
what that we need to change how the
supreme court is run
and if there's probably no political
like
like currency to be able to do that so
the democrats should just pack the board
right and you have no problem with
republicans doing it after that
because they will i do i do but i think
that and then you're remarkably
inconsistent because they will
they will they will and if donald trump
is reelected let me tell you this if
donald trump is reelected
i want him to do exactly what he did now
yeah i don't want him to pack the courts
because just like rbg i believe that the
thing you could do the single
worst action you could take to erode the
americans public trust in the supreme
court
would be pack those courts that's what
she said that's what joe biden says up
until two weeks ago
joe biden said that up until two weeks
ago i agree with him but with with
american alliance nomination in this
nomination right here isn't that
also eroding public trust in doing it
during an election i'm not gonna
i think that they have the right to do
it i think they have a right to do it
but if your argument
is like political is like legislative
judicial legitimacy then you probably
shouldn't do it
during an election year why it's
happened 29 times
i don't understand let's see you're
arguing something that has not been done
in 150 years since the civil war
i'm arguing something that's been done
done 29 times it always happens any time
i'm not going president election year
has a vacancy they nominate it if he has
a unified senate they confirm it
oh that
that's what you do that's what every
president does because
not every president packs the courts the
last time that happened was 150 years
ago in the civil war
but it has a road to trump the supreme
the supreme court is not that popular
okay it has a wrote of trust i think for
the first time in years it actually has
a net positive rating you're right
it was a net negative five and since
brett kavanaugh and neil gorsuch i think
it's now like at a positive six
is it real i've which is still really
bad don't get me i mean it's still it's
still the most like popular i don't like
those odds if i were on the supreme
court
but popular opinion doesn't change the
idea of what the court is
or what that branch of government is and
i'm not really hearing an argument you
said
it erodes doesn't it a road trust to an
equivalent level
for an outgoing president to nominate a
supreme court justice i say no
arguing an equivalent level okay what
i'm saying is that it will grow trust
yeah
and i'm thinking that the republicans
know that if they nominate this through
then the democrats will then there will
be there might be a push
to pack the port so if you're gonna find
a lot more than sure
but if you're well joe biden hasn't joe
biden said many times that
we'll rue the day and he was opposed to
packing course okay he only switched his
opinion recently and he said you'll have
to vote for me to find out just like we
have to pass the bill to know what's in
it well i would say that's dishonest
difference of opinion let's not spend a
bunch of time on that i think saying i'm
against packing courts for his whole
life
until it was politically expedient
saying well maybe elect me i think it's
dishonest you don't well that's not
right
that's not what he said what he said was
i don't want to have this conversation
i think it's uh i think it's kind of
scapegoating the real issue and the real
issues that were in the middle
collection
that's what he said he says insane find
out what he did say you'll have to let
me to find out no no yeah he actually
gave an interview to a reporter where he
said that okay
but what it works i know the statement
you're referring to and i'm referring to
another statement okay
i still think it's dishonest okay sure
we can argue that yeah i think saying
that you're again oh you would agree
with that yeah okay so we'd both agree
with that yeah
yeah the reason it would road trust is
because then you set up a nuclear arms
race where
there's no longer for as much as you
don't like the fact that there are more
slightly more conservatives on
the bench now than there were six years
ago
it'll get a whole lot worse if you pack
those courses there's a reason that we
haven't done i agree with you i think
that that's an issue and i don't think
that it would be good for trust which is
why we need to redo
how the supreme court is working by
packing it no no no not by packing it
by creating more neutral justices okay
and how do you do that
i don't know i think what you had like
pete he argued for a plan was like 15
justices or something like that
and they would be like rotating and it
was like 10 of them were appointed like
neutrally or whatever and then you have
like the like the rest of them however
the math works could be packing the
courts
you'd be adding judges you'd be making a
15 i'd be packing the courts uh
i'll i'll make a distinction between
packing the courts for political gains
and packing the courts first for
neutrality
because you believe that anyone who
would propose any kind of a bill or if
congress were to make some kind of a
vote
you believe that it would be entirely
politically neutral if they decided to
add seats under any circumstances i
can't imagine that scenario
and i think you would regret it if 10
year and you will regret it if that
happens
10 years from now there's a republican
they do the same thing what am i going
for is an ideal world
yeah we have more neutral justices sure
i think that
i think well i don't understand why you
would be against that
well listen we have a system of checks
and balances and we have judges who are
supposed to be impartial
now i do believe that being a
constitutionalist and an originalist
is being an impartial judge i believe
being a judicial activist where you try
and create new laws which is what we've
seen for example with things like
the affordable care act that's judicial
activism
and i think there's a difference and so
i would like to see more textualists i
like to see more originalists on there
who believe in
here's the big difference too see you're
advocating packing the courts or adding
the number
at first you said packing the courts for
political reasons you said you're okay
with that
then you said adding the number to
create more neutral justices okay
everything you've advocated is giving
more power to the government
what i want to see with the supreme
court is a power that acts as a check
and balance
to limit the scope of that federal
authority both by the way
in the executive branch meaning donald
trump and the legislative
everything you have advocated leads us
on a road to
more centralized government power that
can be wielded against you
or against me depending on who is in
power how would more when i am
advocating how would more justices
change the power dynamics of like the
federal branch
adding more justices as ruth bader
ginsburg uh articulated very well in her
opinion
i would agree with her on this i didn't
agree with her on a whole lot sets off a
nuclear-armed race where just someone
can pack
the court with more judges which is why
i think that it'll just every
every new guy will just add more judges
there's a limp there's a rate limiting
factor right now and that's a number
that has been kept consistent for 150
years
and even the democrats were opposed to
fdr when he tried to pack the course
because i said this is really an
unprecedented move
this is not a and this was the most
popular president of
of modern american history potentially
ever this guy won by the kind of margins
they're claiming joe biden will win
right so this is something that everyone
including democrats throughout history
have seen
as a really dangerous power grabs which
is why it should be
more neutral justices but you can't do
it because who's going to pick
what we do and what determines a neutral
justice
i said what in the presidency okay
you want that happening right now with
the current center presidency because
they only get one
you want them to get five picks you want
trump
and mcconnell and lindsey graham to get
five picks do you see the danger
what i'm saying is but you see the
danger i do see the danger i agree with
you i think that it is dangerous
okay but i think that in like a
politically ideal world
it's not it we don't make the supreme
court politics
i agree with you yeah i agree with you i
don't think i think the fastest way to
politicize it more
is to pack the courts which is why we
need to change it to where
it's not it doesn't become an arms race
where you're making it to where you're
like completely change
how the system is done it's an overhaul
to where you aren't so okay these
races so in other words you mean if i'm
not mistaken i don't think this is what
you
what you stand down to me here initially
you were saying pack of course for
political reasons but it seems like
you've shifted and i think this is to a
more reasonable position where you are
saying okay
have a one and done time where we set a
new number of justices
in a neutral way through an act of
likely congress right that's probably
what will be where we set a number of
judges and say okay this is going to be
the standard bearer going forward
is that what you're advocating yeah
great that's what we do with the
judiciary act and we have nine supreme
court justices
thank you very much man i appreciate it
i mean it's political right now
okay thank you i know it failed
[Music]
wake up
hey if you enjoyed this installment of
change my mind click one of these other
installments in the videos playing in
boxes here that's the only way you'll
find them because if you search change
my mind they might not show up
because youtube's deemed them
controversial subscribe hit the
notification bell
and uh you know we'll we'll we'll see
you but we probably won't